the world's climate is changing
temperatures are rising everywhere and
we often experience extreme weather
conditions but is climate change making
us ill when temperatures rise animals
start to migrate including some that
transmit pathogens to human beings
take the Asian tiger mosquito for
example it transmits malaria an illness
that claims some 1 million lives every
year the mosquito can only thrive if
temperatures are warm enough and that's
now the case in an increasing number of
regions because of global warming
malaria-carrying mosquitoes are now
found on higher ground and in growing
numbers of countries plants are also
finding new habitats the common ragweed
is normally found only in North America
but now Europe offers temperatures that
are warm enough for the plant it makes
life difficult for allergy sufferers
and more bad news for those with
allergies as temperatures rise the
period during which indigenous plants
produce pollen becomes longer an
increase in extreme weather conditions
is also a result of climate change
large areas are flooded due to heavy
rainfall and people died in floods
epidemics can spread
mosquito nets can protect us from
malaria and there are pills that offer
relief for allergy sufferers building
homes far away from rivers protects them
from flooding but climate change is
affecting more and more people worldwide
especially those who cannot afford these
solutions so the solution is put the
brakes on climate change